what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder today we have a big
update about the case for Jonathan
Majors we have two massive updates today
and one is that the trial is indeed
going to be moving forward they have
officially decided to go to trial and
the trial date is set to begin on
November 29th now the last time that
they went to court Jonathan major and
his team were still pushing to dismiss
the case Jonathan majors and his legal
team led by lawyer priia chadri
presented a lot of evidence to the judge
to have the case dismissed claiming that
Jonathan major was not an assaulter but
was actually the victim in this and was
assaulted by Grace Jabari his at the
time girlfriend his now ex-girlfriend
however today the judge officially
decided to not dismiss the case and go
to trial so that is the first major
development for the case of Jonathan
Majors he is now officially going to
trial like I said that is set to begin
on November 29th so a little bit over a
month from now now the next major
development for the case is kind of a
part of the first part that we just
mentioned but when they were in court
today according to variety during the
hearing Jonathan Major's defense
attorneys filed a motion to request that
contested evidence remain under seal and
barred from public view due to the
high-profile nature of the case and
allegations against Jonathan major
basically what this means is that the
contested evidence that the da would
have against Jonathan major and his case
would be private and simply restricted
to the courtroom so they could not post
any of that evidence online out in
public so the public could not see
basically Jonathan majors and his team
are trying to essentially protect his
image because it's already been
tarnished a great deal if you're not
aware he's already been dropped from his
management company his PR Company he's
lost out in actor roles he's lost
commercials and as far as we know right
now Marvel Studios are really the only
people who were currently working with
him when this happened happened who
decided to not really do anything until
a judge decides if he is innocent or
guilty which kudos to them because that
is how it should be innocent until
proven guilty and if he is innocent
there's no reason his career should
suffer because somebody made false
allegations and claims against him so
them filing for a motion to request
contested evidence remain under seal and
bar from public view is just them
attempting to further protect Jonathan
Major's image now if you're joining us
today and you're not 100% sure what
happened basically to sum it up real
quick the Marvel actor was arrested in
Manhattan on March 25th and charged with
assault and aggravated harassment after
an alleged domestic dispute with his
girlfriend at the time Grace Jabari
Jonathan majors has pleaded not guilty
to the four charges that were leveled
against him and if he is convicted of
misdemeanor charges of harassment and
assault he will face up to one year in
jail so it's really really big now since
this this has happened Jonathan major
and his legal team have provided a lot
of evidence suggesting that Jonathan
major is innocent however yesterday and
today the opposing party against
Jonathan Majors The Da have stated that
some of the videos and the footage that
they have provided aren't exactly what
they seem however they haven't really
provided any proof that they are not
what they seem there was a
new5 page filing presented to the court
that variety has obtained in which they
state that prosecutors say they are
attempting to get a copy of a London
metropolitan police report from
September of
20122 variety States while it is unclear
what the report contains the filing
references Medical Care obtained by
Jabari at the time Jabari is his
ex-girlfriend and Jabari is a citizen of
the UK and at that time during that
period Jonathan Majors was in London
filming season 2 of Loki season 2 so
they're not exactly sure what has
happened at this time however they are
trying to get the full reports to see if
Jonathan major was connected to this
incident where Grace Jabari his
girlfriend at the time got hurt in
London when he was there this could
simply be coincidental or perhaps there
was some event that went down that is
why they are trying to obtain the
reports to figure out exactly what
happened this document however also
offers new details on the events that
led to Jonathan Major's arrest and
variety has shed some light on those
details variety States on March 25th he
and Jabari were taking a private car
service from a Brooklyn party to their
Chelsea apartment according to the
filing Jabari who worked as a movement
coach alongside Majors on Disney's
Marvel tentpole Ant-Man and the was
quantum Mania saw a text message on
major's phone that read wish I was
kissing you right now she allegedly took
the phone out of his hands to see who
sent the message Majors then began
grabbing the right side of Miss jabari's
body and prying Miss jabari's Right
middle finger off the phone causing
bruising swelling and substantial pain
the filing continues that Majors then
grabbed Mis jabari's arm and right hand
and proceeded to twist Mis jabari's
forearm causing substantial pain to her
finger and arm the defendant then struck
Mr Bar's right ear causing a laceration
to the back of her ear and substantial
pain after he retrieved his phone Majors
exited the vehicle and Jabari attempted
to follow the actor that's when the
defendant grabbed her picked her up and
threw her back inside and sustained
substantial pain including a fractured
finger bruising about her body El
laceration behind her right ear and a
bump on her head according to the filing
now this report actually goes against
what Jonathan Major's team has claimed
that they have video evidence of they
claimed that there were byst standards
out there when Jonathan Majors got out
of the car who can testify that Jonathan
major did not harm her but was in fact
simply trying to get away from her
because she was hitting him they also
have claimed that there is CCTV footage
that shows this however that footage has
not been released to the public however
there has been footage released to the
public of Grace Jabari immediately after
this so-called assault incident took
place partying at a club and in this
footage it doesn't seem like any part of
her is hurt whatsoever the hand that
supposedly had a broken finger is being
used to hold wine glasses and drink
glasses all night she doesn't seem to
have any es on her at the time her ear
does not appear to be lacerated and
according to Jonathan Major's team after
that she eventually would go back to his
apartment in which he would arrive the
next morning and found her passed out
drunk half naked in his closet and
according to them someone from the
apartment building was there and
witnessed this as well because his door
was locked and he needed help opening it
however right now the opposing side of
Jonathan major the DA's office is saying
that the surveillance video referred to
by the defense actually shows Miss
Jabari visibly upset crying and seeking
help from strangers to get an Uber cab
home now I'm not sure which party is
innocent or guilty in this matter but
I've seen the footage it's public and it
didn't seem like she was visibly crying
or upset or seeking help so at this
point in time it is kind of just a he
said she said or point of view for this
video surveillance footage that they
have obtained so the judge has chosen
not to dismiss the case they are going
to court and ultimately it will be up to
the judge to look at all of the evidence
that is presented and determine whether
Jonathan major is indeed innocent or
guilty Jonathan major lawyer priia
Chadley has said that this is a Witch
Hunt against him and if Jonathan major
really is innocent then this is
definitely a Witch Hunt against him
however of course we do not know at the
time if he's innocent then he should
keep his spot as king the Conqueror with
Marvel Studios however if he is proven
guilty and goes to jail for up to one
year Marvel Studios is definitely going
to recast Jonathan major and Marvel
Studios has basically confirmed this
Executives from Loki season 2 and Marvel
in general have stated that they didn't
make a decision because they are waiting
to find out what the truth is
essentially so if he's proven guilty
essentially that's when they make their
decision officially to recast him but
the trial starts next month November
29th if we hear anything in the meantime
of course we'll be sure to do an update
video so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as well
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof